welcome to the final session the
workshop of the final of the final where
we have Rebecca right here from Rutgers
and Barnard who kindly agreed to talk
about accountability computing I'm
really glad I threw this perspective I
think it's a thread that I was hoping to
see in the workshop and it wasn't coming
together and somehow Rebecca managed to
rescue that if it you lasted it up so
good excited to hear what you say it's
pretty much I'll try to to do that job
of pulling it all together and I
appreciate those of you that did stick
around I know it can get a little tiring
and just because some of you may have
questions this is where I have been this
is where I'm going they're currently
both my affiliations but I'm on my way
to Barnard College and I'm happy to talk
to people about that especially those of
you who may be looking for jobs at some
point and are interested in sort of
equal amounts teaching in research so in
terms of accountability this is work
that I started with Joan and Erin in
2011 or so so so for quite some time
we've been thinking about this and it's
evolved but you know really the it came
from hearing both in sort of the
physical world and in internet systems
people talking about the desire and need
for accountability and like so many of
the concepts we've been talking about
privacy and fairness and other things
it's not completely clear what people
mean often it seems to be about finding
someone to blame ensuring some kinds of
consequences for people who break the
rules and so so with that flavor of
accountability in mind I'll talk a bit
about that and sort of what it means
we'll we'll talk towards defining
accountability on a Prevention to
punishment spectrum
and then use that for a couple of
different things so that's useful
because you can situate existing
solutions on this spectrum you can after
sort of thinking about that some more
move towards what we are using at least
as our working definition of
accountability which is a trace driven
utility based definition having that
lets you study accountability itself
both how to provide it but also
understanding where there are and are
not fundamental trade-offs and I'll end
with a little bit of future directions
so as far as setting the context some
examples of people talking about
accountability so there was an article
of White's noir and others in 2008 this
hided or lose it perspective on privacy
copyright and surveillance is
increasingly adequate as an alternative
accountability must become a primary
means through which society addresses
appropriate use and Lampson around the
same time said misplaced emphasis on
prevention security based on locks
rather than accountability security
based on deterrence has resulted in an
unusable security technology that people
do not understand and often workaround
so both of these like we've taken are
very much sort of setting up
accountability as an alternate option to
prevention so Prevention's about it's
supposed to be about making sure no one
can ever break the rules whatever the
rules are accountability says sometimes
people are going to break the rules but
we we have processes or procedures or
methods or things that happen that make
us feel that accountability has been
served even though those rules were
broken versus relying only on this
prevention type approach and of course
accountability has been you know very
prominently in the news in various
context in the last several months
around Facebook and other kinds of
social media also around things like
cryptocurrency and the need to throw all
your buzzwords into one headline at a
time to have more accountability there
as well and so let me give some other
examples of computing scenarios in which
prevention is inadequate so things like
surveillance and
copyright where an agent might first
need to break the policy look at the
thing that it might not be allowed to
look at to determine whether or not he
or she can comply so for instance serve
in surveillance you might need to start
you know an agent might need to start
listening to a phone call to determine
whether the parties involved meet
various regulatory standards of whether
they're allowed to listen to that call
or not and if they're not allowed to
they're supposed to stop and not record
but they had to listen in the first
place various kinds of emergency
scenarios things like the physical break
glass with fire alarms or whatever else
and so that you're not supposed to be
able to get in there but if you need to
you can but there's sort of this
mechanism that makes it a little harder
to do and may provide certain evidence
like like have lots of kinds of data
examples in online life that are
changing all the time things like search
and e-commerce and advertisements
peer-to-peer music photo sharing of
various kinds location dependent
services and various things in social
media including this information problem
that's you know sort of seems to be
balanced against wanting a certain
amount of openness and various kinds of
high volume real-time transactions where
expensive prevention mechanisms may not
be doable for each transaction so
accountability then yeah accountability
primarily with regard to transgressions
not so much accountability that I you
know I've done the competition that I
promised to do or I treated to data in
the way that I promised to treat it it's
hard to know so that good that could be
a transgression right so so so if the we
actually don't get too much into so we
assume there's some kind of policy and
accountability is respect with respect
to that policy so you know if you really
want to instantiate this in a particular
context you may need a language to talk
about what are the policies and so you
might say this is a computation and the
policy is I'm supposed to carry out this
computation exactly so you could capture
that
but but there is this sort of policy
notice at all oh I think I have a note
about it a little later so you know it
there there are these other notions of
accountability that are more closely
tied to fairness and something sort of
broader that's not about necessarily one
entity's behavior and and it's possible
we haven't sufficiently captured that
kind of thing but but but even those
maybe if stated as policies and and and
sort of the broader system carrying them
out but but mostly we are thinking in
terms of some kind of agent as being
responsible for satisfying some kind of
behavior so so yeah so the work that
we've been doing was sort of exploring
accountability of sort of ways of after
the fact or during the fact consequences
as a useful paradigm shift from being
approaches based solely on prevention
and really this has been an issue I mean
in fact issues before computing systems
but it was playing out in real computing
systems since the early days of spam and
peer-to-peer systems and continues today
in many forms and and one of my primary
interests was when I started hearing
people say well we need to attract who
everyone is all the time so we can hold
them accountable and I sort of wanted to
say well that's not true and just like
they didn't have a basis to say it was
true I didn't have a basis to say it
wasn't true and so I realized that you
know my my sort of intuition that maybe
cryptography can help with these things
that seem like they're trade offs but
aren't is there but that without
definitions you you you have no
framework with which to even precisely
answer these kinds of questions so and
so I'll come back to the relationship
between accountability and
identifiability since that was very much
one of my my motivating interests yes
stability but if you can open it some
accounting and some overseas companies
can't be in there you have an identity
but you cannot use it because it's right
so in particular that says identity
doesn't necessarily mean you have
accountability because you might know
who the person is but you have no
mechanism with which to I mean what's an
identity right I mean UK so there's
questions here too like what does it
mean for there to be an identity I'll
get to this a little bit there that you
know that these these answers are not as
simple as they might be because they do
depend on what's the relationship
between people or other sort of agents
and the Ian's you know the names by
which we might know them or the or the
pieces by which we might know them which
may or may not directly be traceable you
know in a practical way to you know that
that link maybe maybe not there as much
and that that not having that link does
make it harder it constrains the way in
which you can provide right so you know
then you have to get into understanding
what kinds of reciprocity it you know
what legal mechanisms and systems you
may have to enforce notions of
accountability but narrow in on what
would it be that you would need or what
would those kinds of mechanisms provide
you or why is it so hard to have
accountability in the internet you know
because it's a matter
so yeah these these are thorny issues
and our definitions won't solve them but
they will help to clarify I think we're
where these problems come into play and
how you might or might not get real so
and and they're you know I could almost
just give out a whole the whole 45
minutes on different words that come up
as relevant when you think about this
and in fact I will spend a lot of my
time doing that in sort of different
contexts so in particular if you look in
in the computer science literature - two
papers or systems that are that talk in
some way about accountability and
providing accountability some of the and
have definitions of any kind that some
of the themes that come up are different
concepts of detection of evidence that
that that it's about being able to show
something to a third party who can do
something with it the thing that they
might often be doing is either making
some kind of judgment or blame or
actually punishing someone certainly
this idea of associating actions and
identities whatever identities means in
a given context and sometimes it's a
more of an ocean of answerability that
that the the accountability comes from
being able to ask questions to that
person or yell at that person somehow
identify the person or entity
responsible for something and make them
talk about the fact that and and again
you know there there's also and I think
you know our initial work on this sort
of predated the the accountable
algorithms thread that's that's very
prominent now and so that's certainly
another notion of accountability
focusing kind of unfairness and
audibility and explained ability and
ethics and especially around these
automated decision-making algorithms and
machine learning so you know I think
that's not completely unrelated but I
would say it is it is different than
what we're talking about here
sorry Katrina if that was what you
really wanted to be hearing about I do
think they're related and maybe
talk about that a bit later so so in
particular what we ended up focusing on
then is a temporal spectrum that you
know so there's prevention based methods
which are supposed to ensure that you
don't even ever get to this point of a
violation and I won't talk too much
about those because I think bility
really comes into play on this side
where you you intentionally don't go
through the high cost or the possibly
high cost of always designing your
systems to enable prevention or you
understand that it's not always possible
and so you want to know what you're
going to do when violations of policies
might actually happen and each of these
can potentially feed into the others so
detection being useful for seeing that a
violation occurred evidence of what
happened judgments around that and then
particular punishment although like I
would imagine an effective
accountability system might be a
prevention technique if the punishment
for a violation is like I'm especially
high that will prevent violation
absolutely absolutely and I should say
you know I I don't feel all that
comfortable coming out and saying we're
all about punishing what we really are
hoping with this is that it's ways to
promote deterrence by aligning
incentives to get the desired behavior
and and in a way that could potentially
be less costly or restrictive to
everyone's behavior than designing
everything to to enforce prevention and
so and definitely right so these earlier
points are often used to enable
punishment or in in sort of the research
context they're they're often just used
as the endpoint and said and then you
know you'll hand that off to someone who
will take appropriate measures and so so
what we want to do with what we're
looking at is shift the focus later in
the spectrum and in particular we don't
we don't want to stop partly along the
way to say it's about identifying
individuals and that you'll get
accountability from that we want to look
at all the different ways that you might
get to this end state of potential
punishment
pterence and to buy it by doing that by
in particular reducing identity
assumptions built into the systems or
any reliance on mappings between
identities in a system and identities in
some real-world context
open systems by not having those
assumptions built into the definitions
it gives us more of a flexible framework
to study the relationships between these
things and similarly to allow for
mediated punishment the kind I was
talking about where you would tell
someone something happened prove to them
maybe that something happened and they
would take an action or automated where
the behavior the very behavior of the
system itself sort of naturally enforces
consequences from misbehavior so and
I'll just talk about so I said the
literature sort of has examples of these
different things so I'll talk through
some of them so a definition 2007 a
system is strongly accountable if it
provides a means for each participant to
determine for itself if others are
behaving correctly without trusting
assertions of misbehavior by another
participant who may itself be
compromised so it's about this
participants in the system being able to
tell that there was misbehavior there's
some evidence-based definitions
accountability is the property whereby
the association of a unique originator
with an object or action can be proved
to a third party or an accountable
system main as a tamper-evident
record that provides a non repeatable
reputable evidence of all those actions
so again the idea that once you have
this evidence you can then turn it over
to some other part of the system or the
world that will enforce whatever kinds
of actions that you want after this
association or identification an
accountable system associate states and
actions with identities and provides
primitives for actors to validate the
states and actions of their peers such
that cheating or misbehavior become
detectable provable and undeniable by
the perpetrator so that has sort of you
know that
the evidence in there and and also that
it that it makes it two identities of
some kind and then Lampson again with a
sort of focus on on punishment or
responsibility at least accountability
is the ability to hold an entity such as
a person or organization responsible for
its actions and so our definition
intuitively is is in that realm so it's
it's focusing on sort of this punishment
based way of looking at it so you could
view it as an instantiation of
lampstands definition we do you know as
you move towards real definitions you
need to start specifying more things so
that you're not just Begley and so in
particular we talk about an entity being
accountable with respect to a policy P
if whenever that entity violates this
policy P which again could be something
very specific about behavior in a system
it could potentially be something more
general than it could be punished in a
targeted fashion we have some
definitions of targeted somewhere and
punished you you might also need to stay
say what the punishment is in in the
context for this to make sense we do
allow a couple of things or allow and
and constrain a couple of things so we
we do want to allow intentionally
refraining from punishment so if the
system has the potential to punish that
should be in some cases enough for
deterrence we don't actually require
that a system be built to enforce that
punishment all the time in order to say
that it meets our notion of
accountability and but we do require the
punishment not just the blame we don't
want to stop at just some kind of
understanding who did something but
actually being able to enforce
consequences and so if that is supposed
to happen out of the system we have to
consider the bigger system that includes
whatever potential punishment there
would be to get accountability on the
other hand we don't require the blame as
long as the punishment occurs so if it's
some kind of automated punishment that
doesn't require the system or other
participants of the system to be able to
identify the violator that
for us is still accountability yeah so
I'm about to give an example that will
have examples of each so let me do that
and then if and if you want more
explanation from a philosophical
perspective it's a it's it's again that
we want to go as sort of as general as
possible to then get out whether that's
doable or not so and okay so examples
like this are great because they help us
build intuition they're terrible because
they can steer your intuition in the
wrong way and you didn't realize it so
I'm sure that and I have a number of
these sort of simple examples that make
some points but they may suffer from
that as well because I do find it
helpful so imagine a car dealership lot
the policy is people can come and test
drive these cars that's a very big lot
so they can test drive it in a lot but
they aren't supposed to be able to drive
the car off the lot unless they paid for
them first and so you could look to
address this policy in various ways that
have various notions of accountability
or prevention so one you might imagine
would be some kind of mediated
identifiable accountability so before
the person gets to drive the car around
they have to connect their identity in
some way to a to a verified real-world
identity of some site kind they have to
find paperwork which sort of gives you
access to the legal system and and they
can drive the car around a lot if they
end up driving off the lot without the
payment then the the dealership can
gather all that information presented to
a judge that could present based on a
punish based on that presented evidence
so that would be identifiable we're
relying on the identification it's
mediated because we're relying on this
judge but it does you know it can under
appropriate validity of these various
things be providing accountability a
prevention based method instead at that
exit you know Matt and there's just one
exit there could have some kind of
electronic shutoff device so that if a
car was driving through the exit it
would shut off any car driving through
and it could only be disabled by the
manager of the
of the car dealership who would do this
upon payment let the person drive
through the automatic version of this
would be the same thing except there's
an explosive device toy example that
would blow up the cars and their
passengers as they drive through the
exit again can only to be disabled by
the manager who would do this upon
payment right you have to worry about
what if the manager doesn't follow the
policy here as well but so this this is
sort of a simplified way that I think
lets you see some of the difference yeah
probe the last example today today we
stated that the customer movie gives
their credit card information and then
they only get the keys after you know
the dealer puts a hold on the value of
the car and then the money is taken if
they driving for life ss-sure sure I
guess that doesn't qualify meet Li and
two identifiable or not because you have
to get into like of that credit card
identify so I like trying to avoid the
idea right exactly I was trying to get
it at something that would would come
across as anonymous so if you if you
replace your credit card by something a
little fancier kind of credential it
yeah yeah be our pile of cash then then
then that could could work for that and
beasts may be somewhat less of Junction
objectionable mechanisms but the policy
is to tell the truth but nobody knows
right right right so exactly so that
I'll mention that later that does meet
our definitions of unmediated
accountability I think it starts to get
at like so I might say sure for me
that's accountability others might feel
that doesn't feel like accountability
because even the system may not know so
so I think that's where you know and
be careful what you name things you know
so so maybe this provides something sort
of much narrower but another way to say
it is is is depending on what you care
about when you talk about caring about
accountability that mater might not
satisfy it but I think just the same way
we feel like if you have a system that
truly provides prevention we wouldn't
say that's not accountable we might not
say it is accountable we might say it
doesn't really apply so you could you
could have similar kind of nuance around
whether you think incentive compatible
mechanisms are are helping to solve
accountability or helping to get around
the need for accountability or whether
they you know are actually directly
accountable because your misbehavior
only hurts you
so right so so one thing we did then is
look to apply our concepts to a variety
of distributed computing systems that
aim to claim to seem to provide some
notion of accountability and so we sort
of went through a bunch of the
literature and of course you could you
could add more things here and looked at
whether and there's not that much in
prevention because we're mostly focusing
on things that we're going beyond
prevention looked at what they were
providing and mostly they they are
really over here so in within their
systems there were usually mechanisms to
detect
what was going on possibly provide some
kind of evidence some of them talked
about how that was used to provide
judgment or blame and in some cases they
had some mediated punishment steps as
well so those concepts are often there
but but many of them really sort of stop
that this idea of just detecting that
something went wrong and providing some
evidence that then would be completely
outside of the system how it was used
and then there were other aspects that
were different as well based on what
kind of information might be available
to whom around participant identity what
the violations were who the violators
were and actions that had to be taken
centralized or not internal or external
and whether the violator had to sort of
stick around to participate or whether
it could be enacted even in absence and
so not going to go through this except
to say you know so again with that same
set of papers and systems we went
through and kind of categorize them and
you really do see a lot of different
combinations of ways that these things
are handled and there were also though a
number of kind of common types of
approaches to get at this kind of
accountability or some kind of
accountability so capture everything
that was a big one and this is sort of
the we have to you know track everything
all the time so that when something goes
wrong we can we can sort of tell what
happened so in these systems like peer
review as an example collect evidence
that allows participants to prove
violations are committed and identify
participants who admit required actions
so messages are logged in a
tamper-evident log
there are Ascenta caterers that prove
that messages were sent and received and
logged you can replay the evidence to
verify that correctness happened and it
does provide a certain amount of
completeness and accuracy with respect
to the things that it is capturing
around messages being being sent that
we're supposed to be sent and behaviors
and so there's many extensions there's
other kinds of audit approaches but sort
of this idea of capturing everything and
making sure you're using cryptographic
or other mechanisms to ensure that the
things captured are actually themselves
accurate another approach that's lighter
weight we've taken by a system called
audit which was specifically looking to
learn about and localize the location of
under you know understand locally where
it was happening loss and delay and
internet routing this one didn't require
rely on the heavy mechanism of
everything being authenticated all the
time
so it uses unauthenticated feedback but
if inconsistent feedback is detected it
goes into this further investigation
mode and in particular if you assume
that any subnet is providing only
correct feedback about itself then nope
you can blame it without leading to
inconsistent feedback so if you anytime
someone would blame incorrectly that
would result in inconsistent feedback
which would only be addressed with
further investigation and some other
broad approaches various forms of
auditing cryptographic commitments and
punishments of various kind within the
system we're really taking the forms
often of either being banished from a
system some kind of loss of identity or
some kind of loss of reputation and
those are for the ones where the
punishment was actually captured rather
than just saying you take this evidence
and present it to someone else to decide
what to do so in terms of our own
research agenda then we were interested
in formalizing accountability or some
notion of it and related concepts
clarifying these interrelated and often
conflated notions to have a framework
for doing that and also to be able to
actually try to provide these things
various systems so usually it is to
study both identity accountability
itself and identity requirements and
systems as well as providing it in
particular sort of trying to be able to
get at you know where there are a lot of
things that sort of intuitively seem to
have a parent trade-offs but
understanding where they really are
inherent and where they're not and again
sort of my personal interest in
understanding to what extent identity is
required in terms of punishments right
like this is very related to also
content moderation where you know you
can say okay there's like either a
certain kind of punishment where I don't
see them in any I don't see any
repertory suggestion you know in content
management imagine that maybe conjugates
flag like you can imagine so many ways
of keeping things going without just
like pulling people out of the system
because I I do get worried about like
making very efficient systems give that
kid like automated Li for April out of
that yeah yeah you gave the car example
but you can literally like have like a
living death yeah yeah yeah yeah no it's
it's it's a good point and - right - to
understand that there's actually sort of
fairness and perhaps even accountability
in a larger societal sense around the
questions of what are appropriate
punishments or or actions maybe not even
strikes and you're throttled right right
right right and also like when is it
appropriate to have monetary
consequences versus other kinds of
consequences like again like
that you can do distributed badness like
if you think about for example some of
the racialized attacks on Twitter its if
you would look at each individual
attacker you would not find something
that is punishable mhm
here one person receiving 1 million hate
messages is right right and and so there
I think even all of these models come in
to very problematic space because you
can't all of a sudden up by something as
hard as a hammer I do I wonder like what
what kind of challenges kind of yeah
yeah yeah that right that that bad
outcomes happening to a person don't
necessarily have a strong punishable
event on the other side it is the somló
interesting and everything we think
about the systems being more and more
about population management do not like
individual right then that kind of stuff
becomes really interesting to give an
account of yes but also for individuals
that are in that process it's somehow
affected by to be able to give their own
account so that you're not just looking
at that accounts of the service provider
so anyways I right all right yeah I like
that sort of the account as a stand up
and be heard not not to talk to someone
but to be listening to so yeah
that's lacking from how we
conceptualized so far
so right so this is a sort of another
one of this times where I'll talk about
you know or at least highlight again
sort of a bunch of different concepts
that seem to be sort of tied up with
each other and we could add others
around yeah sort of this reparation or
well I guess compensation is sort of
similar there as well here in this you
know systems up here because it seems
that a lot of the things you might hope
to do are much easier to do in sort of a
more closed system whatever that means
and harder to do in a more open system
and so the kinds of things we might want
to be able to ask as a research question
then is say in open systems with
mediated punishment or anonymity and
accountability compatible and again that
was the end of that is what interested
me in it question becomes more
interesting when you get at some of
these other specific things around them
so I think I'm I'm not I have way too
many slides so I think I'm not going to
go through any of this except to say
that you know and the more the when you
want to get to proving theorems you need
to have even you know more concrete
definitions and so we have a traced
based notion of a system and in
particular then we assume you have some
predicate that is a policy and in
particular but you have a violation
predicate that can tell you if various
points in the system have a violation of
that policy and then we also assume that
there's some kind of utility functions
defined on outcomes of the system which
are necessary for us to know when
something is a punishment you can do
this for sort of various forms of
utility and and we want to sort of
generally you know we
we want to be as general as possible but
specific enough that we can say useful
things and then we also not shown here
but we do rely on a notion of causality
and different notions of causality will
give us different kinds of results but
but we're assuming that you know we use
some other notion and so automated
punishment
probies question would would well not
quite coming back yet but automated
punishment would basically be a state
where you've got these you know you've
got a system going along and then after
a violation happens all of the states
afterwards have lower utility for for
the violating principle than the others
and so that would be some kind of
automated payment where the very act of
the violation puts the the entity that
that carried that out in a worse state
yeah sorry one side back do you require
that the violation predicate be
something that once it's violated any
sort of extension of that trace or is
could there be a remedy state yeah I
don't I don't think we modeled that but
I think it would be nice you know again
to sort of assume imagine you could have
sort of a steady state of a system where
there may be temporary violations and
they're remediated in some way and the
system goes on fixed
we didn't model that but I think that
makes a lot of sense for sure you know
and especially if you want to move away
from just punishment to sort of consider
sort of unhappy states of the whole
system and happy states and your goal is
always to move unhappy states back to
happy states we have different ideas
about what's happy and and how we define
that and but yeah if I think right this
is this is sort of our view of the world
kind of stops at the violation and the
punishment and it doesn't really sort of
state a state in the mediated world then
again you have a violation and you have
various behavior that can go on
afterwards and then we want to have some
kind of imagine the world with the
violation that should have eventually
some possibility of a punishing event
and you have the world without the
violation which may initially sort of
look worse off but but ultimately you
should have been better off for that
violator and right and depending on the
specific notion of causality
if the punishing event and the violation
event can themselves be the same that
specializes to the automated notion so
right and so there and then we had to
spend some time sort of getting at this
question of identities and principles
are the things we think of as real
identities so a person or a company
names are possible identifiers Zoar or
unique something or others within a
system and the nihms in the system are
the things that take action not actually
the principles and unless they happen to
be collapsed and you might or might not
have sort of a clean boundary of what a
system you're considering is and if you
then want to talk about who can take
actions and affect who and links between
them it gets a lot more complicated
and have violations which might or might
not be detected you can have punishment
wouldn't blame but they might be
independent and identity and
identification or about these mappings
and blame might go to the principal or
just to the NIMH and so there's a lot of
different things that can happen here
and so again some more formalization has
to happen that lets you get at saying
that right that a principle P act on a
system as an in if the principal is able
to if the yeah if the name takes actions
that were sort of on behalf of that
principle of violation predicate holds
on actions you might have
blameworthiness on principles and so
sort of getting at all those different
pieces and so again some examples to
help sort of clarify some of these
things so let's talk about software
vulnerabilities so suppose Alice acting
at some gnam and finds a software
vulnerability and there could be a trace
in which TP in which she too close
discloses it responsibly which we
generally think is a good thing and a
trace te in which she exploits it which
we generally think is a bad thing or I
think that way and but if Alice can
obtain sufficient payment for the
exploiting option of the vulnerability
she may choose that and her ability to
do so without repercussion may depend on
the extent to which she can be
identified meaning her name and can be
re can be connected to her identity
Alice and so if you want to get it
whether she's going to be incentive to
do this or not
as extremes you might have to consider
these two differences one where these
mappings that map identities principles
to NIMS where every principal has
exactly one NIM that we go about our
lives as our own full identity at all
times and effin on an anonymous mapping
we're all principals are mapped to the
same name and there's a lot of
anonymity and obviously these have
different implications of how
identifiable Alice would be while she
does this and in particular if she can
be identified she may also care about
increased or dis decreased reputation
right she may not like it that you find
out that she exploited the vulnerability
or she may actually be in some sub world
where she gets to use that as status so
so that's just sort of showing how some
of it plays out what actions she may
want to take may depend closely on her
ability to be identified and right so
punishment I've been hinting at we think
of as in a utility theoretic way because
we need some constraint or structure in
order to be able to prove things if
versus the utilities could be absolutely
anything but we do
where possible want to stick with
general and meaningful classes of
utilities rather than very specific
examples and again we want utilities
that are gonna depend both on the trace
like what are the things happening but
also as in that example with the
sovereign depend on the connection
between the principles and the names and
and we want in our formulation the two
parts to be separable so that we can
facilitate this study of the effects of
the connections between principal the
names whether you have strong identities
or or not and so the way that we've done
this then is generalized and quasi you
linear utilities to consider the
utilities with linear transfer and so
this was our you know sort of keep two
classes but be a little more specific
and in particular this is useful for us
to be able to capture reputation based
approaches to punishment where we're
looking at being able to sum over all
the names associated with a given
principal the effect on those names and
because in particular a principal might
accrue benefits to many NIMS and
punishment only to one or vice versa and
we want to be able to understand that so
then coming back to this identify
ability and accountability question is
it possible to have accountability
without identify attentive viability and
like so many things the answer is it
depends and I'll do a couple more
examples so imagine a state fair and
again this is sort of a system we think
of as having a fence or a boundary so
some some kind of closedness to the
system but anyone can buy a ticket
without showing identify effective
education they could pay cash or
whatever else but the fair does want to
know who has and hasn't paid to the
extent that those who have not paid or
not let in but it doesn't necessarily
need to do more there might also be
additional kinds of tokens wristbands or
something else for additional privileges
maybe you've shown proof of age for
alcohol or purchased ability to be
treated better within the system and but
if someone violates the fare rules
whatever they are the Pharos artis might
want to be able to identify them so that
they can take appropriate actions
possibly punishment or at the very least
ask that person to leave and so
depending on what you do here you know
so it might be they don't need to they
need to identify the NIMH and tell that
NIMH to leave but they don't need to you
know an escort that Nitin perhaps to
leave but they don't need to relate it
back to the to the identity and but it
may or may not have multiple kinds of
NIMS with these different properties
similarly in an auction house you can
have these paddle numbers that serve as
unique identifiers within the auction
house but the system that the entities
in the system auctioneer and other
bidders don't need to know the real
identities but because there's value
involved the auction house typically is
going to require real identities or at
least a cash deposit so that itself is
protected so coming back then Jacobi's
question so automated punishment and
incentive compatibility so incentive
compatible protocols do themselves if
you assume that the policy is you should
behave according to your your true
valuations then then incentive
compatibility compatible protocols
actually provide automated punishment if
you act not according to your true
valuation you're only going to
potentially hurt yourself no mediation
is required
for the punishment it's all built-in
already to the protocol and if the
protocol doesn't require identification
then by our framework this would serve
as being accountability without
identification without a team innovating
so but but but this starts to get it
like you know so if this make if this
makes you feel like it's not really
accountability maybe we've not captured
the things you know that you care about
when you think about accountability and
right and as I was saying you know there
seems to be very much not formal but I
think we have some notion of open
systems where users can come and go and
they might or might not be anonymous but
there might still be some requirements
of participation closed systems much
more tightly regulated and you need to
establish some kind of identity and
maybe all the participants can see each
other real systems both both physical
world systems and online systems are
often somewhere in between and you could
talk about the the State Fair in that
context as well so towards being able to
say something about this we have some
definitions of a closed system open
system and strongly open system which
basically talk about how much ability
the system has to identify the
relationship between the nihms and the
principles and so in that context then
we can finally sort of put something a
little more precise on this research
question that I wanted to answer in open
systems with mediated punishment or
accountability and a man anonymity
anonymity compatible and so there's even
more definitions in here I didn't even
give you but you'll be able to
understand at least what they're trying
to talk about and with that we can prove
if an open system is always able to
punish a blameworthy principle in a
targeted and mediated way so targeted ID
tell you but meaning they don't just
sort of blanket punishment punish
everyone as a way to try to get it
punishing the principal then for any
violation II that the violator takes the
system must have realizable principle
attribution for evey so either it can
tell who the principal is or it must be
able to decrease the utility of the nin
that took that action such that the
decrease
utility must be larger in magnitude than
the sum of all the increases and
utilities for the other names and so
that's a bit wordy and if you put it in
math it's even more wordy but also more
precise but what it's really saying is
that if the system is open so it's
unable to determine who what principles
act as an MN and the punishment is to be
targeted and mediated and the violation
can't be linked so the set of principles
are like related to the violator so
there if there is this strong anonymity
then the punishment must be meted out
through the NIM used for violation as
opposed to going back through the
identity and must be done in a way that
must offset any positive effects that
the principle might gain on other names
so so it is the case that limited
identity constrains how punishment can
be affected so that's sort of one vote
for the yes you need identity to have
accountability on the other hand things
like the incentive compatibility or
about the other way that says you you
can have accountability even without so
so you know what basically it says
you're gonna have to if you want to have
punishment without identity you're gonna
have to do it in other ways to try to
understand this theory yeah and this I
think is my last interesting slide so if
I'm trying to promote my song or my
website on reddit I can create a bunch
of spam accounts and spam my website and
read it and if already can do is ban
those spam accounts I'm still getting
utility then or you're saying that if
banning my spam accounts doesn't isn't
enough to counteract the utility I'm
getting from the website the only way
for it to punish me effectively is to
find a way to link these accounts to me
and find a way up right right thank you
right they can either write if they can
either try and find a way to punish the
violating NIM
or in such a way that it offsets the
positive effects or they have to do
these other things they have to write
somehow okay there you don't have to say
very long so right I mean so now I just
want to jump up many many levels right
too why do we care about this cuz
there's lots of good things about
today's technologies but you know also
all these potential bad things security
breaches privacy invasion the
weaponization of information other
things we've been talking about all week
and accountability is an important goal
and a way to try to prevent some of the
bad behaviors and combat some of the bad
behaviors in some ways both for
individuals and for providers and that
why do you care about making these
definitions you know it's it's so that
ultimately you can design better systems
and help decision makers and users make
better choices
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so so we know that I am the
last person between us and a party so I
will keep my comments very short and
sweet don't you read your emails sorry
there's no party anyways so so good do
what I draw draw some ties between this
work and a lot of the words that are
often used in the same sentence as
accountability things like they earn its
privacy transparency you can kind of
talk about the ways in which actually
these are on like different axes so so
first talk about privacy and
accountability because I guess after all
after all it is like a privacy that
semester I think this work really shows
accountability and privacy don't
necessarily have to be at odds but in
fact these are actually like two
different axes and we can kind of pick
where do we want to be along these two
things and they don't and they don't
actually have to be the same choice I
mean so there's the like example that
it's capture everything that is highly
accountable but is not private at all
and I think this work shows actually if
there's like a whole lot of other space
in which we can play as we think about
privacy versus accountability one point
to make for kind of like the folks in
this room is that in this case as I use
the word privacy I don't actually mean
like a differential privacy I really
mean being identifiable versus being
anonymous and some space in between
there and so I think almost had this
great great point
the really having your identity shown is
not the same thing as being accountable
especially if you're talking about
different laws where maybe I can be like
identified as a violator but I can't be
like Oh
punished and so maybe having the absence
of privacy it isn't even isn't even
enough to enforce this and I like to
kind of pose as a question how can we
tie things like this together but over
the language of like on differential
privacy is there a room for this here
and there's been a small amount of work
in the DP space thinking about thinking
about how to do differential private
punishments and that is appropriate in
some cases and not in the others if
you're talking about how about like
uploading up cars maybe you don't want
to do like a probabilistic punishment if
people even if they paid for the for the
car and so I think that there's not
always a connection between this and
like MDP but there may be a space to
kind of to kind of think about like a
probabilistic punishment and that was
explicitly allowed as the slide said
allowing intentionally refraining from
enforcing punishment so this is like
allowable and the framework and it may
be kind of like a context dependent
choice if that's an appropriate thing
the other word that we we lose a lot in
the same sentence it's like also
fairness so there's so there's this like
ACM conference fast our fairness
accountability transparency but really
this kind of work is very different for
the kind of accountability that we think
about in terms of fairness and trying to
enforce the policy don't steal cars is
very different and like enforcing make
fair college admission decisions
especially because that policy is not
quite well-defined that we saw this
morning Hey Aaron's talk and some talks
earlier that earlier this week all a
challenges involved in defining fairness
and so this framework requires a very
precise definition of the policy after
which punishments can be enforced we're
not quite ready to start doing this for
our fairness problems but this seems
like a very excellent
framework to kind of start start seeing
are there variants of this they can be
more compatible with a kind of
accountability that we like in our
fairness problems maybe it would be
easier to say I can't like I'm strictly
enforce fairness but a but if they do
see a very blatant fairness violation
maybe then maybe then these tools can be
brought to bear for that
and the last thing that I wanted to say
has about on it is comment about having
but having about having about having
distributed punishments I think that's a
really interesting technical question
where you have where you have kind of
like a lot of people colluding in a
small way to create some pretty heinous
violation
maybe if I send one mean thing online
it's like okay that's not great but but
I'm not gonna like explode your car this
is my favorite example but at the same
time if one person receives like I'm ten
thousand mean things on Facebook they're
actually experiencing a pretty
significant violation even if there
isn't one specific person to blame and
so this has a fantastic question
probably outside of this framework like
in this case what type of like
punishments might be appropriate in this
case and from the like crypto community
we have things we have things like I'm
trader tracing schemes although I think
this is kind of like a different moral
problem it's it's not quite the right
the right the right tool here because in
this be because these tools typically
assume that I have like a that I have a
small group who who kind of like each
individually commit the same violation
and so it's like and so it's like fine
if I punish one because the same because
the same copyright infringement would
have occurred even if there's only one
person doing it it just so happens do we
have like a group of them whereas here
this is more like saying who knows like
I'm not gonna like you know go after one
person because they make one mean
Facebook comment but the fact that we
had like each person individually doing
it then a large group creates a
violation they may not exist if there's
only one person doing it and so I think
the
can kind of give us ideas of things to
really think about but we probably need
new technical tools and more kind of
like of those topical approaches but the
right punishments there I thought can
all allow you to field your own
questions
[Applause]